Leeches.
For most people, they're the
stuff of nightmares.
But there's a lot more to them
than just slimy bloodsuckers.
Now, the leeches in this tank
are medicinal leeches, and
they've got this name for
a really good reason.
So for about 2,000 years, up
until quite recently, it was
thought that the body's health
was kept in balance by
substances called humours which
flowed through the body.
Now blood was one of those
humours, and if you had bad
blood or too much blood, then
it needed to be drained.
And that is where these
guys came in.
Draining the blood from
the body was known as
bloodletting.
And using leeches to do this was
the height of fashion in
Victorian times.
In fact, millions were used
every year across Europe.
Leeches are actually worms
related to the ones you find
in your back garden.
But these are parasites
that suck the
blood of other animals.
And they find a host by
detecting shadows and movement
in the water.
So if I dip my fingers in the
tank and wiggle them around,
the leeches should come to me.
And there we are.
This is Larry the leech--
or it could be Lucia.
Leeches are hermaphrodites.
They've got both male and
female body parts.
Now this one is hungry.
You can see it's desperately
trying to find
somewhere to attach.
So I'm going to let
it feed on my arm.
When leeches are feeding, they
inject anti-inflammatories and
an anticoagulant called hirudin
that stops the blood
from clotting.
And it's because of these
that they're still
used in medicine today.
They drain blood clots
and promote blood
flowing skin grafts.
People say that leeches inject
a kind of anaesthetic so the
host can't feel it feeding.
Now, there's actually no good
evidence to support this.
And I can actually feel this.
It feels a bit like a
mild nettle sting.
And what it's actually doing is
using three rows of teeth
in a kind of Y shape.
There's about 100 teeth in each
row, and it's using these
to slice through the skin
to suck the blood.
It could take up to a couple
of hours until it's fully
engorged, so all we can
do is sit and wait.
The leech has been feeding
for about two hours.
And as you can see it's
absolutely massive, but it's
showing no sign of
stopping yet.
Now, I don't want to try to pull
it off, because if the
leech feels threatened it might
regurgitate is stomach
contents back into the wound.
So after nearly three
hours the leech has
finally dropped off.
And the wound is going to
continue to bleed for at least
two hours afterwards.
Now the leech can last
on this single
meal for over 12 months.
So I'll see you the same
time next year.
The human volcano--
fire breathing.
It's the most dangerous stunt
in the fire eater's
repertoire.
But how does it work?
Well, it all hinges on the
oxygen in the air.